jigsaw you're special on Netflix I want
to have some statistics here in jigsaw
you say because your act really does
cause a lot of breakups mm-hmm has
causes a lot of couples that see Daniels
act tend to break up and you are
responsible for I think even before
jigsaw came out you're responsible for
4,000 breakups 17 canceled engagements
and nine divorces a and that number has
now gone through the roof right yeah
since jigsaw came out 25 thousand
breakups about I think it's 75 council
engagements and 80 divorces know how
many divorces 8808 zero divorces okay we
have a picture here this is a picture of
you signing something backstage or RF
what are you signing that is someone's
divorce papers they came to you and they
were ex their fans and they said I want
you to sign this no no's my wife she
completely different spin on it yeah you
kind of have to sign those eventually
yeah I should tracked me down to told me
no so a fan brought those yeah so
somebody one of the many divorces I
caused they brought along like will you
sign this and I was like I think that's
dollar Pfizer's because I don't need to
sign it right it's not like they're like
okay here's the person tubular getting
divorced and then the person that
randomly calls to otherwise a bunch of
kids would have to sell you divorce
papers yeah yeah yeah it's actually
you're right you're right and not all of
you were responsible for your parents
breakups but most of you yeah
I think kids need to hear that that's an
important it's made it's the message of
my next show hey kid it's your fault
yeah if it wasn't my fault it was yours
very nice